tisser du lien avec les entreprises du
canton de saint cyr c'est une volonté
première adjointe économique deuxième
réunion du tout nouveau club des
entrepreneurs de saint-cyr-l'ecole
groupe créé à l'initiative de la mairie
objectif rassembler les différents
acteurs économiques de la ville autour
de thèmes d'actualité ce soir
l'intervention porte sur l'intelligence
économique
l'idée c'est aussi de pouvoir offrir une
thématique qui soit transversale et
qu'ils puissent être audible écoutable
et qui puisse servir tant à
l'entrepreneur qu'aux commerçants qu'à
la petite entreprise du fait déjà de la
crise du fait qu'on sait pas trop à qui
s'adressait comment se faire connaître
c'est pour ça que les petits déjeuners
ou daft europe organisé par le maire
peuvent peut-être nous apporter plein de
choses mais le groupe compte une
quarantaine de membres installés sur les
communes de saint cyr fontenay et bois
d'arcy pour en faire partie
il suffit de s'inscrire gratuitement à
la mairie de saint cyr pour recevoir le
programme des événements